[Music]
we're gonna go through our experience
kind of how we got to be on GCP and what
our experience has been when we got
there and a lot of things that we
learned we're also going to talk about I
guess some of the things we might have
done differently if we had our time
again there'll be plenty here for
everyone I think really happy to be here
with a couple of my teammates I'm Marco
dilatory I'm the CTO of derive systems
over in the blue shirt is Scott Nelson
who's a director of software and
deejaying this event is Jim mountains
who's our data science team lead so we
can have some really fun demos from
these guys talk about architecture and
also just get a sense of how we fit in
the world so I thought I'd start out
just letting you know what we gonna be
up to so a bit of a primer on our
industry we're an automotive IOT so we
put little devices inside vehicles that
do really cool things they're all te
connected they collect all sorts of data
from vehicles and they also rewrite the
software of vehicles so one of the
things that sets us apart is that we do
vehicle write access to make vehicles
more capable than when they get to you
from the factory so we'll talk a bit
more about that give you a sense of kind
of what the market opportunity was that
we went after obviously do some fun
demos cuz that's what everyone's here to
see and then talk a little bit about the
tips and lessons learned that we had
from doing all this so we'll start out a
little bit I'll talk a little bit about
our industry just give you a lay of the
land for those of you who are about to
or have already started building an IOT
platform a lot of this is going to apply
directly this will just give you kind of
the surface layer of how our customers
are special to us but obviously all the
firmware cellular connectivity mobile
apps the data flows that's probably
going to be really familiar we hope it
is because we want you to learn as much
from our experience as you can so this
is a little bit about the history that
precedes us that derive so really dates
back a number of decades as things
started to become connected and smart
and digital so starting out with going
to the PC and more recently our
connectivity becoming linked to
smartphones even our homes going smart
how doorbells are smart now this is one
of my favorites our ovens are smart now
it's pretty cool
shoutout to anyone from June oven who's
in the room I think the only one tops
that is their cell toothbrushes going
smart this is really something that the
social media networks are trying to sell
me right now I haven't seen toothpaste
GU smart yet but I think that's probably
next so the question is why is the
biggest appliance in our lives maybe one
of our biggest assets in our lives also
one of the least smart connected or
integrated and that's a these little
guys on the right-hand side why are
these things static after we buy them we
get to choose the paint maybe a couple
of options we drive them off the lot
they never change again in fact they
drive off the lot not even knowing how
we're going to use them are we gonna be
using them for law enforcement or for
delivering packages or picking up
groceries or dropping the kids off at
school the OEMs don't know so they build
them all the same a little bit about the
industry we've playing and moves very
slowly
there are about 270 million vehicles in
operation in the u.s. today so a lot of
vehicles on our roads
each of those vehicles has a lifespan at
about 11 years so if you do that math
now it takes a real long time for the
industry to change the vehicles that
roll off the lot today gonna be out
there for a dozen years it's gonna take
15 20 years for the industry to change
the entire set of vehicles that are on
our roads just to highlight that some
more the first modern vehicle appeared
around 1901 you can debate what modern
vehicle is but that's about right well
we had about 95 years of that 96 the
first electric vehicle happened here in
Silicon Valley we think a lot about
Tesla we'd hear a lot about Elon and his
folks man it's been more than 20 years
since electric vehicles started and now
there are little over 1% of the industry
so this industry moves really slow while
it's moving slowly we love the idea of
everything going autonomous and electric
and maybe flying or who knows what the
reality is these vehicles are out there
with incredible networks of processors
running software that we can upgrade so
what we've gone about to do it derive
and what we offer to consumers and to
fleets is the ability to modify the
software inside vehicles to make the
mission specific so that means whoever
you use that vehicle will give you the
software that
does that mission best okay it's
something we've been doing for consumers
for a long time it's something that
we've just recently in the last few
years started doing for ana pliers
fleets and were the only people that do
it and we do that through an IOT device
that goes in the vehicle and that's a
real big differentiator for us because
we're the only ones that write the
software so we're going to talk about
the platform that kind of powers that
differentiator first just to give you a
sense of why this works so if any of you
out there ever use kind of a Fitbit or a
health device I built one of those one
time yeah humans really difficult to
change this software of you guys so we
think about this in terms of enterprise
fleets what's happening out there our
devices are collecting information about
vehicles so for example how fast the
vehicles going or who's driving it fleet
managers are coaching drivers like hey I
see you're speeding out there be great
if you didn't do that tomorrow it's just
like the Fitbit like hey 9,000 steps
today
how about 10,000 took like really hard
to change the habits of humans right so
we're out there trying to coach these
drivers drivers are doing the right
thing about 50 to 80 percent of the time
and by the way each year about 20 to 30
percent of the drivers in a fleet leave
so you get to start again with that 20
to 30 percent so it's really tough to
win this battle in the automotive
industry I think the biggest thing that
drives failure here is that these
behaviors are at odds with operational
KPIs so if you think about drivers in a
fleet that have to make a number of
stops each day sorry got to make eight
stops today so I don't know picky on you
you're just closest to me you got to
make eight stops today to get your
paycheck
okay but you're not allowed to speed
well if you get to stop seven and so
most the end of the day guess what
you're doing if you get stopped eight
you're breaking that speed limit all day
so one of the challenges is that
operational KPIs are directly at odds
with how people drive the vehicle so
because we have right access to the
vehicle we're thinking about this a
different way we modify that the way the
vehicle operates so it doesn't matter
how you drive it so for example I can
stop that vehicle from speeding you can
put your pedal to the metal it's not
going to speed so here's a case study
that kind of talks about these three
things saving lives
lowering environmental impact and
technology that pays for itself for
these big appliances this is a big major
national fleet that we work
with so let me just walk you through
this real quick there were two lines
here are injured Blue apologies those of
you who are color blind but I'll walk
you through it it'll be obvious anyway
the blue line represents that control
group so these are vehicles that we
didn't upgrade the software on at all
and as you can see over time being the
bottom axis now these people keep
speeding speeding violations just
continue and these folks were coaching
their drivers telling them not to speed
pleading with them not to speed and
humans just keep speeding the orange
line is a test group so this is the set
of vehicles that we modify and you can
see at the start man I wasn't doing so
well I started out in the sim applies
the sped a lot we upgraded the software
those vehicles so they wouldn't speed at
a level the fleet deemed unacceptable as
you can imagine if the vehicle can never
exceed that speed violations go to zero
so that's the difference between trying
to change the software of humans and
changing the software vehicles bit of a
video about us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right thank you lay of the land so
for those of you who are building IOT
platforms or thinking about being
building IOT platforms that's kinda
world in which we live
building IOT devices that go inside
vehicles that have a really unique
differentiator that connected this is
our product market opportunity so think
about your product market opportunity
it's gonna fit a lot of the same things
in our case we deal with these vehicles
that are running generic software we
live in a commoditized Tim telematics
industry so this is just folks who are
out there measuring GPS location and not
able to write to software vehicles
that's about an 18 billion dollar
industry
we brought mission specific vehicle
software upgrades it's a big
differentiator but of course we also
offer telematics and all the commodity
features as well and we built a platform
it goes after this and brings it to
market and we're gonna kind of walk back
through how we got to that but
ultimately combining those four things
meant three key features for our
customers one being fewer collisions
just drivers out there having fewer
accidents and if they're having
accidents they're much less severe
secondly having a small smaller carbon
footprint so we reduce the amount of gas
that vehicles use which has a huge
sustainability benefit and lastly lower
costs by reducing the amount of gas that
fleets are consuming in their days
they're spending a lot less actually
pays for the technology itself so nice
little market dynamic there where by
making the fleet less expensive to run
they can afford to buy our technology
and then some when we looked about this
product market opportunity and selecting
a cloud vendor the kind of three main
criteria we looked at first was speed to
launch we saw this huge market
opportunity in this 18 billion dollar
market with this unique engineering
capability we wanted a partner that
could support us to get right into the
market as quickly as possible we want to
go capture this thing well were the only
ones that could do it second thing we
were getting huge market demand signals
because no one else was offering this to
enterprise fleets so we wanted a partner
that could scale with us so not just
launching quickly but then being out to
meet the demand that came with that
and lastly we're putting connected
devices inside huge machines this has
got to be secure from board to cloud and
back again so these were the three main
vectors for us and obviously we chose
Google so I'm going to kick it over to
Jim Jim's gonna talk about how we went
from really nothing to standing up our
first fleets athletes typically send
about 20 million data points a day and
Jim had to stand that up from scratch
making it happen so Jim no video
hopefully I'm coming across I had to
move the mic good about a turn maybe
he's still getting a little bit of that
it's really impressive that all the
tools that Google and GCP provides
especially to those that are trying to
get started with IOT the communication
to IOT as some of you may know I know
some arms that went up in here earlier
but is MQTT there are open-source
libraries through PAHO and documentation
on getting devices registered and set up
in the cloud really quickly it was
important to us to get a proof of
concept and have data coming from
whether even they be virtual devices and
getting those push in the cloud and have
that just that pathway established to
understand how we would take that same
technology or that same methodology and
bring that over to the firmware so for
this particular I won't go too deeply
into it but I'll take a one of these
open source PI Python files and slightly
modify it and then send some data up
currently just to show kind of end to
end will first off take one thing that's
nice about this the Stata script is or
this particular Python script is that it
establishes MQTT connection and sends
that data up into the cloud that we can
then verify like I said we'll change a
few things when it comes to the data
payload this data payload is very
particular to us is something the types
of things we care about especially when
tracking a vehicle so we're talking
about latitude longitude speed those
types of things we're not gonna get too
creative but we will update the time and
maybe we'll change the latitude as well
or we can change the course in this
particular time
all right so again this script is simply
going in and pushing up the the payload
that we've selected for given virtual
device and then we would like to verify
that that data is gone out here we have
our demo next device 19 now our process
for this is sending data into bigquery
it's from bigquery that we pull all data
for analysis and any other processes
that we're going to do analytics further
on down the road as we can see we've
recently sent the most recent message
the data we know is coming through this
is not just helpful for proving that we
have a simple data pipe going from end
end but this proves particularly useful
when you're doing development further on
down the line when you're trying to do
testing trying to do any sort of scaling
testing anything along those lines
trying to do it here before you're
actually trying to push these changes
into something much more complex such as
firmware or these IOT devices their
insight vehicles of course the GCP
console gives you access to many many
things from being able to track devices
that are inside your system or being
able to track monitoring of said devices
of course we went from a development
environment to looking at what is
actually production for a fleet that is
an existence that is sending out up to
20 million messages in a given day
you're able to try Trant traffic or
monitor the traffic for MQTT traffic
device operations
errors which are luckily quite low byte
traffic and what is the billable data
that is being sent across in our
particular model we're sending already
to IOT core and then that data is being
processed by serverless functions or
cloud functions is a case maybe again we
said we tend to see a similar kind of
pattern in this case where we get to see
the traffic or cloud functions that are
being instantiated over the course of a
week for ourselves we see that there
seems to be a particular kind of
and this is particular to our our art
IOT use case in which a case we have
drivers that are in in a fleet and their
typical traffic is peak for mid day
across the United States and then in the
evenings we see quite a decrease in
traffic refer ourselves personally even
those these devices aren't sending on a
quick regular basis as if they were
actually in traffic or actually moving
our device to still send data even when
they're not active necessarily just to
let us know that where they are and how
they're doing and then if we look at
something on the weekend we see less
traffic which is pretty expectable one
hopes again there's a wide range of
information that you can pull from
different cloud platform graphs and
charts understanding how many different
instances are being served up to handle
the kind of traffic that's coming
through one thing that's really
important to us is looking for spikes
spikes are what tell us that possibly
something is going wrong or there's
something that when we're sending data
whether it be to bigquery or a third
party endpoint for collection and other
processing it's those spikes that let us
know that there's there's a problem and
kind of alerts us to some sort of action
another important tool especially if
your days being passed through cloud
functions is to watch for any errors
that might be going across they require
further investigation a lot of the times
when you're sending twenty million
packages in a day you're gonna get
errors whether that be possibly internal
connection errors to where you're trying
to save the data or external errors to
where you're trying to send the data to
one thing that's really powerful about
IOT is that for pub/sub which is what
IOT feeds into is that if a message
doesn't int reach at endpoint if there
is an error it isn't lost it's sent back
to the beginning and generally speaking
this is what you see with spikes is that
data didn't reach its endpoint and it's
gone back to the front of the queue
and we'll try to go again at a later
time metrics and ability to observe
what's going on within the system goes
much deeper and typically this is within
stackdriver stock driver allows you to
set very specific parameters on what you
may be wanting to watch whether that be
big query reads big query rights or
anything within the entire GCP platform
that you need to monitor what's more
powerful than that and has proven useful
time and time again is being able to set
alerts within stackdriver such case
might be that SQL usage is reaching a
point that it might cause problems and
people who have developed on GCP know
that there are set limitations resource
limitations and api limitations and you
can set alerts and policies within stock
drivers that allow you to be know a
problem before it occurs before it stops
and causes problems within the system
and with that
awesome
shameless round of applause for Jim for
a live dinner brave cool so that gives
us a sense of just how to how we went
from zero to getting the backend going
and we'll come back to the architecture
a little bit ago to walk us through that
but once we got the back-end working got
the data flowing in our system to
support this volume for our fleets we
started to build the user experiences so
obviously now building the data flows is
great but a customers have to have
something to work with so here's some
examples of things that we've built and
we're building for our customers so
obviously starting out with web and
modal did mobile data so ways for
drivers to interact with the system as
well as fleet manages through dashboards
and visualizations we offer distracted
driver prevention so when the vehicle
comes out of park we lock the phone down
so drivers can't be sending SMS or
making calls it's one of the leading
causes of collisions and we just take
that right off the table by making sure
that if they're in Drive or they're in
reverse they're not texting see pocket
enforcement we're really excited about
this is one where it prevents the
vehicle from even starting and
the seatbelt is on we know that most
collisions in a fleet happened within a
really small radius at the start of a
drive that's also the time when you're
least likely to have put your seatbelt
on yet and for a driver in a fleet
that's making eight stops a day or 12
stops a day it gets kind of a hassle to
take that seatbelt put it on and off
every time so they tend to skip that
well that's why they get an accidents
and hurt themselves and others so we're
taking that off the table by making sure
that that seatbelts on every time and
lastly dynamic speed governing so we can
offer fixed speed limits for vehicle so
that vehicle just never goes above a
certain number we're starting to do
dynamic speed governing as well so
looking at the location and heading of
the vehicle and applying the speed for
that road or speed relative to that road
to the vehicle nobody needs a delivery
vehicle doing a hundred miles per hour
down their street to get to the next
stop
so we stood up the back end we started
to build the user experiences and it
took off we work with many of the
nation's largest fleets now including
one of the top five and that one fleet
generates about twenty million data
points per day and has more than 25
thousand vehicles so even as we just
started to build this thing the demand
was there and it's only taken off since
so going up to that higher level of
experiences turn it back to GM and show
us kind of how we turned that back end
of IOT core and pub/sub data flows into
user experiences for our customers so of
course just establishing the data is
kind of getting from point A to point B
isn't entirely that useful
bigquery proved to be one of our best
tools for identifying devices in the
field that might be causing problems or
just not behaving as we expect them to
you identifying individual errors with
logging while at times was useful it
didn't give us the kind of insight to
help us dig on particular issues being
able to find specific vehicles and how
they're behaving was a simple thing to
do within bigquery
there are other types of queries that
prove to be quite useful like trying to
identify devices that haven't reported
GPS in some amount of time all these
devices that we have they have LTE they
Bluetooth and I have GPS connections so
while is your
maybe also have GPS the device is
supposed to be reporting its GPS at the
same time there's a number of reasons
that that might not be happening you may
be in the city scape or a valley that
doesn't have GPS or at the end of the
day the driver takes the vehicle and
parks it in a garage or it gets taken in
for services and so for all intents and
purposes this device kind of disappears
to the fleet possibly so being able to
find these vehicles that aren't
reporting as we expect them to is
something that's particularly important
we can then go in and try and track down
what's happened to those devices now all
these tools very useful for ourselves
internally while we're in this
development process while we're trying
to go through these steps of setting up
this fleet of 25,000 vehicles or any
fleet that we're working on but it
doesn't really add much value to the
user as Marco said that's what we're
really trying to drive towards is get
something that's useful that for them
for tracking data for being able to
track their fleet manager fleet gives
them real value we were able to do this
relatively quickly with again using just
a Google a Google product being able to
pump data from bigquery into data studio
which allowed us to without using
bigquery and it's something that's
better 211 internally in some cases be
able to track down specific vehicles
when they last reported when they last
pulled information that they were
expected to fall but then we wanted more
than that and so for that we needed kind
of library on our architecture of hill
back to the slides thanks Jim
this is drives Google cloud architecture
it's simple but when we started it
didn't feel simple for us we had
excitement we had confidence but we
didn't have experience for building
architectures that will handle twenty
five million messages a day we took a
very iterative approach to this as marco
and jim has mentioned and I highly
recommend building this in layers and
building layers upon it mr. strategy we
did during development and trying to get
to market quickly and it's a strategy we
leverage for our roadmaps and for
further capabilities that we had and I
would like to walk through the flow and
sort of highlight some of the big
milestones I'm starting with our device
in the vehicle so as Jim initially
demoed a big milestone is is working on
your ingestion and storage and getting
this set up in a proof of concept to
really start seeing your data that you
wish to flow through the cloud and get
the tools that you need to really
visualize it
this was empowering for us from a
development perspective this let us
check off a lot of architectural
considerations that we had IOT core
really proved out the scalability and
security pub/sub with the reliability
being able to handle data spikes that we
see from time to time in cloud functions
with the stateless execution of
horizontal scalability on bigquery
bigquery is a tool that we leveraged a
lot
the sequel nature the ability to see
data in very cost-effective queries is a
platform that we really developed to to
really see what we were trying to build
and enable quite a few things it enabled
us to really dive deep and try to
visualize what we wanted to create in
applications and identify data integrity
issues is our is our devices do they
have issues with the metrics that
they're streaming and it helped identify
missing metrics for the capabilities
that were
trying to capture and this is a
milestone that allowed us to iterate and
do full stack changes in a pretty
efficient manner so as we start seeing
more metrics and ingesting them we can
work with that without really impacting
the rest of the stack the next piece
that's pretty critical that for us has
been a challenge and is ones that we
were excited to continue to work on
these data processing so for our our
messages from vehicles these are very
specific events in time and we need to
process that and start having some
higher abstractions for us
that's trips that's seen a individual a
driver for a window of time go to
different locations it strips and it's
the insights that we want to show about
trips specifically that I'll get to and
when I show off a little bit of Mission
Control when I'm with data processing we
actually went through a couple
iterations of it it was definitely a
learning for us on how did this cost
effectively and there's quite a few tool
sets that we haven't leveraged yet but
we have in our future when it comes to
the actual applications itself this is a
little bit more in our wheelhouse this
is what we've been developing for years
so it's really the data architecture
pipeline that at least for us with our
experience has been a great learning
experience so for Mission Control this
is our dashboard this is our web
application and what you're seeing here
is our first insights that we built the
graph in the upper left is showing
insights on engine idle time this is a
fleet and the graph shows the total
amount of time vehicles were idling each
day it's a very simple powerful
visualization and for this specific use
case we have a positive outcome of the
idle time decreasing the this is caused
by a couple of effects one is leveraging
our ability to upgrade the software on
vehicles to help reduce the auto time
and in the second is just more
visibility in cannibal
with individual drivers if they
understand their patterns and they do
have an opportunity to try to optimize
set and similar to our layered approach
of our whole data architecture pipeline
it comes up all the way to the end-user
applications as well when we built this
we didn't have other visualizations we
didn't have data processing that went
deeper than this
and as we added more capabilities to
Mission Control we continued to add what
we need this is the sort of opposite
approach the set of insights this is
going into high fidelity and this is
looking specifically at a single chip so
this is more of a real-time and detailed
representation of our data processing
system and in this one we're still
highlighting a little bit of the value
out of the system with showcasing not
just the GPS locations but the amount of
idle time during that trip and from that
I'll pass it back to Jim to really
highlight some of the lessons learned
and not not on the demo but actually
just on the slide today oh yeah you got
it so I think one of the biggest lessons
learned for us really had to do a lot
with the how best to most cost
efficiently leverage bigquery bigquery
is an incredible tool to cheaply store
data it's a great data warehouse and
it's simple enough to pull data from it
but we had multiple systems both from
trip processing to just simple mapping
that we were trying to do that the times
could be pulling thousands of queries in
a minute we had to change that we had to
optimize a lot of the ways that we both
store data and change data if anybody
has worked with bigquery when you start
getting into the terabytes of terabytes
of data on bigquery some of the most
important things to keep in mind is make
sure you use partition tables so that
when you're pulling data in you're only
pulling the data you want ultimately
when it comes to cost that's the biggest
thing with bigquery typically you don't
need access to all of the data that
you're possibly storing for us that can
be particularly true when we can have
hundreds upon hundreds of columns of
data that we're storing for any given
event that comes across so partitioning
particularly important and making sure
that you leverage your queries against
those partitions sometimes we still see
that happen within our own where why did
that one cost that much why did that one
singular query cost that much so trying
to limit that another really great thing
to do is denormalization the data a lot
of us come from the background of
relational databases and in that kind of
an environment you're thinking oh it
joins or no big deal we'll do that but
again when you're running lots of
queries against huge data sets you don't
want that you want denormalized data
just have it in one table so you're not
doing joins on many many many queries on
top of that again trying to make sure
that you you're only pulling the data
that you absolutely need stackdriver is
your friend it's a great way to keep you
from running off the rails it's all too
easy
that's the it's all too easy in GCP to
kind of shoot yourself in the foot they
give you all the power you're willing to
pay for it and so using stackdriver
which they give you you can set things
up to keep you kind of on the rails and
alert you when things when you've
possibly done something wrong things
we've tried to avoid very similar to
that you know leverage leverage
stackdriver to try and avoid hitting or
going over quotas before you find out
because your services have started to
stop just shut down because you've hit
your quotas and another thing is
especially in environment it's important
that you that you have a good devops
group or that you have some sort of a
devops operation because again it's
really easy to set things up in your
environment on GCP and you can forget
that they're running and they're not
necessary so yeah and again about the
same really leverage the tools within
the infrastructure to to help you keep
things in track with what you expect
there's a lot of different services and
they're always changing and they're
always adding new features to help you
and and that Google is really quick and
responsive when you come into issues
that you need to deal with one thing
that's been very helpful to us it goes
beyond there's the initial billing that
you have but you can take all your
billing information and you can load
that into bigquery and you can load that
into Data studio and really do deep
drilling to understand what the costs
and usages within your entire
organization systems are and there's a
summary that's a peck DeMarco Jim thank
you very much yeah we've actually just
started piping the data back into from
billing back into bigquery it's it's
been a huge asset to us so maybe that's
for a future demo but would really
encourage everyone out there doing these
kinds of initial builds to make that one
of your out front priorities it's helped
a lot just to run back for a moment I
know a lot of you are sort of thinking
about or initially building would
encourage you to look at this
architecture and kind of consider it as
a reference or a resource and
if it's something that you're looking at
in terms of building a connected device
and standing up at initial architecture
we'd love to help so come talk to us
about our experience I think I'm set you
know we had some lessons learned but all
in all was a pretty smooth experience
and especially when it comes to support
I think that's one of the things for me
that I would have changed about our
experiences to lean on the Google folks
earlier and more often I think we were
probably a little bit overconfident in
terms of building things and once we
lead on them a bit more that was a huge
support so please take note of this
architecture it's working great for us
and we're extending it from here and if
we can help you with yours
don't hesitate to reach out so I just
wanted to kind of end on a summary of
our experience I guess we needed a cloud
partner we had a pretty amazing
opportunity and a unique differentiator
when it comes to our feature set so we
went out and kind of shopped around we
chose Google for those three vectors
kind of speed to launch and and it's
been less than a year that we were from
kind of a vision on paper to a platform
supporting some of the largest fleets in
the country support for scale which is
now something that we're thankful for as
we do that and then obviously security
which we didn't have as much time to
touch on but something would love to
talk about as well we have launched
successfully and with some great user
experiences for drivers and with
dashboards and visualizations which
we're really excited about and we're
growing the business from there with
Google we learnt a ton most notably that
the reasons we selected this platform in
this architecture actually bore out to
be true so it's easy to hear this stuff
up front it's really relieving when they
actually turn out to be real and with
huge support from the Google cloud team
they've really been pretty amazing about
this next up we're really excited about
kind of exploring more of the m/l side
of the platform we're collecting a huge
amount of data now and we're kind of
doing with it what we know best which is
working with fleets directly showing
them their reality and then upgrading
their vehicles to get those benefits so
they don't have to rely on driver
coaching but we're excited about what
we're going to learn from this data that
we don't already know so really excited
about that and really appreciate you
kind of letting us walk you through from
our first kind of idea through the
initial building of the backend through
to the user experiences and where we are
today and happy to answer any questions
or what
to get and help you guys build yours too
so thanks for the time
[Music]